the movies been designed to be to be to
draw you in and to make you feel as if
you are experiencing what it might be
like to set foot on this undiscovered
landmass that's that's a wilderness and
is untouched by man I think an IMAX will
draw you into the film in a different
way
the silence notorious for the number of
ships and planes that have gone missing
actually seeing this island like the big
sweeping landscapes because we shot in
such incredible beautiful locations that
are real I think it'll be worth it to
see you'll just get totally taken over
by this place well people should
definitely go see this because it's
uncanny how far we've come with you know
like graphics and CGI and all these
different things ancient species on this
earth long before mankind there's a
helicopter ride through a hurricane and
out on the other side they think they've
seen the worst of it but there's a
hundred-foot prehistoric ape waiting for
them that's calm he's King around here
we talked a lot about Indiana Jones and
Jurassic Park and also the great war
movies of the 70s and how you really
feel the stakes in those films but it
wasn't gonna be so serious that you
would lose that sense of fun that goes
along with being on a great adventure
you can put that down we wanted to make
a almost old-fashioned movie with this
romantic notion of adventure but also
with a really fresh contemporary edge
that was kind of rock and roll and
subvert adir expectations that was
always intended right from the very
beginning it's back to monster movies
shifted it to the 70s so it feels a
little closer you know something that
feels more grounded more realistic it
really was about giving you that
experience of I feel like I'm watching a
great movie and it's a big epic monster
movie oh man
I think this is like the movie to see on
IMAX
I mean our main character is like a
hundred feet tall so it feels like IMAX
is like the place to go I think you have
to see this movie on the biggest screen
you can find with the loudest sound
system you can find you have to be
immersed in it and that's what IMAX
delivers
you
you